si è così successo ma che è successo la
mano a scomparsa c'è scritto qualcosa di
nuovo
se uscire vorrai 2 indovinelli risolvere
dovrai o no io pensavo di aver finito
pensavo che l'enigma della mano fosse
quello finale invece devo ancora
risolvere due indovinelli ecco perché
c'era una freccia qua il teschio cosa
vorrà dire però questa che cos'è una
scatola nuovamente il lucchetto c'è
scritto qualcosa sopra
mi chiamo
c'è scritto ma gli occhi del teschio si
sono illuminati se provi a rompere la
scatola si distrugge
se proprio a rompere la scatola se
distrugge se provi a rompere la scatola
la scatola si distrugge il gremio ha
bisogno di qualche lezione di grammatica
comunque ho capito cosa vuole dire
infatti nell'altro video mi avete
consigliato perché non sfondi tutte le
scatole ed essi così magari rompi rompi
i muri con le scatole ed essi ma ho
paura che i treni poi si arrabbia e
perdo subito la challenge quindi
purtroppo non posso barare quindi non
possono per questa scatola cose si tuffa
ma devo nuovamente risolvere qualcosa
qua con il lucchetto che si acquista c'è
scritto aspettate prima e meglio si
accende una luce altrimenti non riuscirò
poi a trovare tutti gli indizi allora le
luci questa è un'altra scritta se tieni
gli occhi chiusi ti viene a trovare che
paura cosa vuole dire oddio paura di
chiedere gli occhi adesso qualcuno verrà
a trovarmi se chiudo gli occhi
accendiamo la luce e proviamo
innanzitutto da aprire questo scatola
magari ci può servire per riuscire a
risolvere gli indovinelli e di altri
enigmi
ok apriamo la luce apriamo la luce
volevo dire accendiamo la luce su un po
confusa in questo momento stava tutto
questo buio
allora si che cio questa è la mia mano o
no è stata gremi sicuramente quando
piazzato la mano li deve aver sostituito
una mano la sua mano con le sue dita con
la mia mano cosa vuol dire forse grady
sta cercando di trasformarmi in g cioè
non proprio in graham in un'altra cremi
cioè grendi vuole che diventò cattiva
come granny iniziato tra la mano per
fortuna il braccio non me lo ha preso
ancora però penso che più il tempo passò
qui più mi trasformerò in una sorta di
granny o in uno scheletro non so quale
sia il suo piano malefico quindi è
meglio che mi sbrigo mi raccomando anche
voi dovete aiutarmi a risolvere questi
indovinelli e iniqui prima che mi
trasformo in non so che cosa non so
quale sia il suo piano comunque mi fa
molto strano avere la mano così
accendiamo subito le luci
ecco fatto molto meglio un'altra qui
molto meglio adesso ora spengo la pila
mi sento un po meglio con questa luce
non so se devo prima risolvere questi
indovinelli di cui parla granny questi
due indovinelli anche se ne ho trovato
solo uno finora o se devo aprire queste
scatola prima ma secondo voi cosa devo
fare prima però non so ma mi imprese di
più questa scatola
mi sa che proverò primo ad aprire la
scatola perché sono troppo curioso di
vedere cosa c'è dentro secondo quel cosa
c'è dentro provato indovinare nei
commenti prima che la pra e poi magari
dentro la scatola c'è un altro indizio
per risolvere magari questi indovinelli
visto che dobbiamo fare in fretta
ok vediamo qual è l'enigma da risolvere
per aprire il lucchetto questa volta
allora c'è scritto i fantasmi del
castello si stanno divertendo in
trappola ha intrappolati criptando gli
indizi di cui hai bisogno per uscire per
uscire trovano in diffida e c'è da
cercare sui dischetti sostituendo ogni
lettera con la lettera ad essa
successiva in ordine alfabetico
se vedi una per esempio sostituisce con
una b inizio 1 2 e 3
ok innanzitutto prendiamo i nostri
dischetti questa volta devo stare
attenta perché nell'episodio precedente
non avevo visto torta e in tantissimi mi
avete scritto contorta l'hai detto tante
volte perché non ero troppo il manico e
non me ne sono accorta quindi anche
questa volta cercate di stare attenti
massimi a me e cerchiamo di trovarli
insieme
ok innanzitutto di sparkle kg così forse
verrà meglio dopo trovarli poi abbiamo
le due carte speciali
se non sapete di cosa parlo andate a
vedere l'episodio precedente
e poi la gigino strano che fa vedere le
parole del
ok siamo pronti questioni ma spero di
riuscire a farcela in cinque minuti ma
ogni volta il tempo vola 0 riuscire a
farcela altrimenti non scoprirono mai
cosa c'è dentro questa scatola inseriamo
la carta torniamo stante il via il tempo
partito o click sbrighiamoci subito
allora il primo indizio f quindi io devo
prendere la lettera successiva nel
progetto quindi la lettera successiva è
gfc poi la lettera successiva ha pr
quindi r quindi grh i gr i fdg rg grid
per giù di aver capito
h m e grigio ok devo trovare la parola
al grigio con mezzo sbrighiamoci questo
è grigio wow l'ho trovato subito viva ok
una ce l'abbiamo
lasciamola qua andiamo all'indizio
numero 2 r il tempo di 3 agosto
scorrendo di devo sbrigare r avvisi di
fegica ilm m.ro nel panico devo ripetere
tutto l'alfabeto
oh sì oggi il mio piccolo stv
[Musica]
dov'è la k o in quello inglese e dissidi
dj j kay euro
l ok o school st o cous o sbagliato
qualcosa e avvisi di fisica il video
piccole sculture aiuta
non riesco a capire che parola è questa
aiutatemi voi ho sbagliato qualcosa
aspetta mi è venuta l'idea c'era il
pennarello kafka è meglio che lo
scriveva qualche parte così forse riesce
meglio il tempo trascorrendo ok andiamo
al passo con la scatola speriamo che
credi non si arrabbi allora innanzitutto
dopo la r dopo la r s
ok perché chi veniva la o poi sbagliato
qualcosa
dopo la b c'è la c quindi costituzione o
più core st forse ho capito che l
ma dopo la tappa cela l giusto che
c'entra la l manca la troviamo st school
fa la scultura con lombata non rendermi
ricordo molto perché pensavo se stai
scrivendo scuole sbrighiamoci
sbrighiamoci voluto subito che fortuna
questa volta
forse la mette due minuti deve trovare
l'ultima parola allora l mht e kld miele
ok sbrighiamoci sbrighiamoci verde
questo caso di vedere con la carta
speciale ma gestito la scorta quasi ha
scritto per qua c'è scritto broccolo
questo ha scritto blu
ho già scritto dall ok fosse qua vediamo
c'è scritto spezie
proviamo con questo allora richiamo c
quasi una torta questo un libro cinema
molti lavori ultimi spiegare dava questo
lo devo vedere con la carta verte esse
deve dobbiamo trovare miale velocemente
questo un gelato cuscino rosso o no
scuotendo il tempo
questo è un libro minuto pagnotta viola
e forno orologio scritti bianco candela
per me lo trovo non c'è
dopo pochissimo tempo tenuto eccolo
viene sbrighiamoci allora quello blu e 7
1234567 quello giallo 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 ott i ragazzi se l'abbiamo fatta
all'ultimo momento c'erano solo tipo 19
secondi non ci posso credere che ce
l'abbiamo fatta veramente ogni volta mi
viene il panico quando faccio questo
gioco ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok salviamo il lucchetto possiamo
finalmente aprire la scarsa vediamo
quanti di voi hanno indovinato vediamo
cosa c'è dentro
oddio ho un po paura di quello che
troverò qua dentro
che cos'è un sorta di pistola che faccio
pro premere il grilletto
ho paura che distrugge tutto oppure che
richiami g andiamo non succede niente
che cosa vi dover servire forse devo
distruggere le spip
con questa una sorta di fucile laser che
devo fare
c'è qualcos'altro qua dentro lo so che
cosa è che serve questo vediamo se c'è
qualche instruttore sezioni il
territorio che proviamo ad accenderlo
forse per quello che non funziona ma è
poi proviamo a sparare a qualcosa
[Applauso]
queste si illumina di verde e questo di
più
che cosa vuol dire che sono viva che ho
delle ditte che cosa vuol dire proviamo
nuovamente fai silenzio perché fa così
tanto rumore così che rende viene subito
qua
proviamo succede niente che cosa devo
fare
forse si può sparare a questo caso che
non funziona ma che devo fare
non ci sono le istruzioni occorre felice
un biglietto ok forse è meglio che nel
frattempo spengo questo quasi non fa
troppo rumore
ok facciamolo poi vediamo cosa ci è
stato detto
ok è sempre un biglietto di granny c'è
scritto è arrivato il momento di
combattere
se vinci tu io sarò sconfitta e tu sarai
libera ma se vinco io non potrei fare
più video su youtube
quindi vuol dire che dovrò combattere
gremi con qualcosa
ora vediamo se riesci non mette a fuoco
ora vediamo se riesce a uscire firmato
granny ma come sera il confine conta
altro di votare mi ha gettato questo
corso per combatterla perché siamo
ancora per soffrire e lo devo risolvere
quei 22 idee migliori dimenticata che
non si costringiamo questo io non penso
di essere brava con i composti fucili
laser ma speriamo di riuscire a
sconfiggerla con questo forse devo
puntare a questo coso
ma questo è il mio forse grandina tra 1
e dovrà puntare a questo speriamo di
riuscirci penso che sarà molto difficile
batterla ma per ora mi devo preoccupare
di uscire fuori di qui e quindi riuscire
a risolvere questi indovinelli io vedo
solo un indovinello comunque che è
questo se tieni gli occhi chiusi ti
viene a trovare guardiamoci intorno
qualcos'altro nascosto dice sempre la
freccia con lucchetto ma abbiamo già
risolto questi due enigmi
forse il teschio utile qualcosa guardate
qua è apparsa una scritta a fianco alla
x6 scritto è tuo ma lo usano più di
altri
non è l'idea di come risolvere questi
indovinelli questo mi sembra più
difficile di questo allora andiamo con
calma proviamo a risolverli
uno alla volta e voi dovete aiutarmi
assolutamente allora se tieni gli occhi
chiusi ti viene a trovare quindi a
trovare se tengo gli occhi chiusi di
venus che ha in mente una cosa per
dimenticata che questa pila.it post
regata e si muove da sola proviamo a
spostare tutto vediamo se mi dà qualche
indizi che cercano la rimane fissa a
montare lì forse c'è un indizio lì o
forse vuole solo dirmi che devo
semplicemente risolvere questo
indovinello proviamo appoggiarla qua non
si muove il piano come l'altro volto
dajti la fregata aiutavi fai qualcosa
punta sempre lì e penso che voglia
semplicemente dire che devono funzionare
più devo risolvere questo indovinello
aiutatemi a pensare allora se tieni gli
occhi chiusi ti viene a trovare cosa può
essere che ti viene a trovare si tiene
il game si è tenuto in mente un'altra
cosa
una cosa che ti viene a trovare quando
tieni gli occhi chiusi e il buio perché
quando chiudi gli occhi e il buio però
non è proprio che ti viene a trovare nel
senso lo vedi subito il buio quando
tieni gli occhi chiusi
che cosa può essere aiutatemi mi è
venuta in mente una cosa
l'unico modo per scoprirlo e provare
quindi proverò a tenere gli occhi chiusi
per un po e vediamo se riesco a capire
qual è la soluzione a questo indovinello
se volete fatelo anche voi così magari
viene in mente anche poi potete scriver
melo nei commenti siete pronti a
chiudere gli occhi
12 in ora vedo solo buio
cosa potrebbe finir mie trovare adesso
non penso che la risposta sia al buio
proviamo a fare un po di silenzio e
vediamo che succede
i ragazzi mi sto addormentando non
funziona questa cosa di tenere gli occhi
chiese altrimenti mi addormento aspetta
un momento se io tengo gli occhi chiusi
per lungo tempo mio tormento come tutti
tutti si addormentano si tengono gli
occhi chiusi
quindi forse se tiene gli occhi chiusi
ti viene a trovare e la dr mento no non
si dice così in italiano come si dice
il sonno il i sogni i sogni prodotti
viene a trovare singolare quindi il
sonno forse la risposta giusta ragazzi
cioè non lo so se la risposta giusta ma
penso che sia quella più logica
voi cosa ne pensate che cosa si può fare
per dare la risposta ora graham i gremi
penso che la risposta sia il sonno non
risponde nessuno
forse devo forse devo scriverla con il
pennarello
ok proviamo ho molta paura di quello che
succederà al se scrivo la risposta
sbagliata non so se gremi mi terrà
intrappolata qua dentro per sempre o che
cosa succederà
ben lo scopriremo adesso assieme andiamo
a scrivere la risposta
e poi proviamo a risolvere il secondo se
sarò ancora in vita
quando scrivo la risposta vediamo
ragazzi provo a scrivere la risposta qua
sotto
speriamo bene
[Musica]
sto scrivendo tutto storto
speriamo così la risposta giu
la pena si sta muovendo sta succedendo
qualcosa tu che questo voglia dire che
era la risposta giusta perché non è
successo niente di grave anzi c'è stato
un suono come se qualcosa si stesse
imprendo o sbloccando e sommossa anche
l'aquila quindi immagino che sia la
risposta giusta in vivo nel vivo già
risultino meno male
ok ora dobbiamo risolvere il secondo che
mi sembra molto più difficile è tuo ma
lo usano più gli altri quando sa può
essere mio ma la usano più gli altri
devo pensare a cose che sono mie
che cosa c'è lì mi viene in mente il
computer ma non lo usano più gli altri
il cellulare ma non lo usano più gli
altri lo uso più video che gli altri
cos'è che la usano che gli altri ma il
miglioramento e niente dovete aiutarmi a
capire qual è la soluzione di questo
indovinello non mi viene in mente niente
ho paura che piano piano mi sto
trasformando in carelli il tempo sta
scorrendo quindi scrivete nei commenti
secondo voi qual è la soluzione le
soluzione sembra che abbia più senso
lasciate anche mi piace ai commenti che
secondo voi sono la soluzione giusta e
proverò a scrivere una delle vostre
soluzioni sperando di riuscire a vincere
penso che dopo questo indovinello
potremo uscire fuori dalle sky problema
quindi aspetto la vostra risposta mi
raccomando scrivete nei commenti e
lasciate mi piace questo video se volete
vedere il continuo il prima possibile
facciamo raggiungere il 20 mila mi piace
a questo video
crimi si sta avvicinando la sento
[Musica]